hey everyone this is Miguel concepción
and I am with Eric Tay and we are here
to show defiant honor the second DLC of
neo all right so the tompa's so yeah
it's a close-up weapon pretty cool
follow these guys there was that
stormtrooper guys awakens oh dude that
is so cheap
that's like Dark Souls 3 DLC like the
exact same thing when you see the ghost
archers and you're like oh that's kind
of cool oh [ __ ] yeah it's like if I want
to defend the game like the cutscenes
kind of warned us that that was gonna
happen
I guess ok hopefully this works right
yes man that's like glad it's like
gladiator
oh this so this was the bait right here
not only me following those guys tomb to
their death but uh clearly I have a lot
to be worried about here there's a guy
afraid he doesn't even want to move so
at least there's like a queue right like
an audio queue like rigging of those
kind of like the Gong Russ speak yeah
big giveaway
you get hit in the trenches all right
what's up with this guy think you're
open enough it was he gonna give us oh
we got a giant can of all times too well
we've got cannons in this game got lucky
and we like that some of the combos in
it oh what's that
do what smash okay I feel like the some
of the combos in this game are very
reminiscent of Ninja Gaiden yeah yeah
definitely
oh there goes his head if you it feels
pretty good though that's the top was
especially if you like kind of getting
up and close what was your kind of
favorite weapon when you were playing
you know after putting in about 90 hours
it sounds so corny but I found a reason
for to use every weapon oh really yeah
you know a sort of general interest in
experimenting Plus think I mean thinking
that certain bosses were weak against
certain other certain weapons based on
like just the potency of like us using
the sword at high stance shoot what
what's the the chain weapon kusarigama
yes I always butcher that yeah it looks
like just not to cut you off there you
can keep talk telling me about your
weapon after this but I guess it's
shooting the cannon of which we had two
cannibals stop the barrage at least of
arrows from that one area well that's
one effective cannon yeah I know right
it scared them away oh that's a nice
combo yeah I'm surprised there isn't
like an insta-kill for being helpless
like sneak up oh this that's cool man he
useless to like you're sweet like he has
like a rapid-fire swing essentially with
meat on place that's pretty cool oh
sorry so back to your favorite weapon oh
you kind of played in them all right
right well and you know I hadn't
explored a lot of the older side
missions and so it was I don't know what
that Co okay it was a nice reprieve to
explore the older side missions leveled
up and that gave me an opportunity to
just play around with all the weapons
but I mean I like game similar to neo I
do appreciate that it gives you
incentives to try out all the weapons
Kodama there but there's a rain of
arrows what do we do do risk our lives
we save his is it still raining arrows
yes
okay well I think we're in a different
like spot now see yeah I hear the gong
oh that's alright
it did happen an open goal to definitely
teaching a lesson right off the bat to
beware of the flaming arrows it's like
almost some Lord of the Rings crap where
you know the orcs are attacking that one
basically castle and they had they were
able to rain down arrows except I'm one
man and I don't have an orc army - uh
okay we broke the barrel which is good
oops
don't mind me just trying different
combos here
was it worth it though does a guy hit
obviously oh yeah right it's over here I
do like that you do earn the weapon
pretty early in the DLC I mean really
early feels yeah I'm just gonna like
grab it and like use it in the earlier
yep in the main game alright so there's
no way we're getting hit right correct
elicit went through that really tiny gap
just just to get our little buddy out of
there all right
raining arrows versus William of neo who
will win
I think the arrow is whit's maybe we can
get a candid shot off on that
now that
oh maybe I'm not okay with a candid
all right all for the sake of the
shortcut worth that was worth it do not
care do you not care all right
screw you and your cannon fire you jerks
so Eric did you actually using the save
file did you actually complete seal
scene one
I didn't finish all DLC one I did I get
that stream with you right previously
where we kind of Oh what is this guy
it's a dog it's a ninja dog there's a
ninja okay I feel so terrible I'm a dog
killer Oh God usually in video games
when a dog is armed usually it's just
like a melee weapon in its teeth this
one actually could throw kunai yeah he
he was packing you don't see his body
because dead but he had like [ __ ] eyes
on the side of his uh his head like he
had you know like get a bunch ready to
go going back to our discussion about
the lc1 it's comforting to know that if
you just wanted to play this siege stage
you can buy this DLC as a standalone
yeah at $9.99 yep or you could buy the
season pass which i think is 20 was it
20 29 at 24 oh there's a dog speak of a
dog
Oh what he's fast
dude that was his head oh he's coming up
the tree proper pathing hide in the
house yield in the house do they know
how to calm down oh that answers that
oh please go to sleep
oh I'm getting rekt slight patches so
that is for sure a new enemy though the
dog the ninja dog oh my god they're
everywhere you think I shot him that's
not so awful
well the headshot didn't work I think
you got it I think I'm in charge
yeah monster I don't know why I said
yeah feels bad man ooh see Kodama back
to that could not want are important
obviously if you haven't played neo they
increase the amount of lectures we're
allowed to have when you get back to the
yeah among other upgrade settings but
you can only activate one of those
settings at a time
it was awfully brave considering he had
barely any health level Adam all right
we meet your max familiarity with the
tapas is good oh oh this guy look at
this guy
you don't see me anymore huh you're
pretty loud I don't know how I did not
see me there but I'll take it
Oh No downstairs he's got there was a
shortcut though I'm follow there's a
yokai there choices choices right these
are the choices we make and regret
probably yeah cuz why not
okay
whoa
we got lucky oh that was weird
I thought he would hit me for sure no
matter how nice it was to get the ninja
mobility skills I I discovered it like
30 hours into the game oh that was a
good effort on that shot I'm scared I
have no way to heal nothing like that
tension that hot tension that's our
betting man I'd say there isn't a shrine
at the bottom of that well no no there
isn't but there's this shortcut back to
the shrine oh there you go that we had
earlier so I'm gonna definitely go there
and then run down to the downstairs area
I guess down that that well area but the
problem is we're still gonna alert them
to get to the well so question is how
will they follow us down the well
that is all the dog I was gonna say I
had as visuals Oh like the dog going
down the ladder rung by rung and I will
say I was in the middle of looking up
some of these historical figures in this
DLC in Wikipedia namely sanada yukimura
and ila and I loved that in the Google
searches when you now put in the names
of these seungu Sengoku era historical
figures it just brings up all these
image results from Co e games we had a
boss looks like it really what if it's
like a master Doge
see nobody nor do we like this guy
mr. agreeable Oh what does he have oh
he's got Tom Plus - OH
we're gonna show me who the master the
tompa's are I have no elixirs right now
I've faith in you oh thanks
[Music]
whoa
and turquoise an armored pills
okay okay we'll try again know what that
means isn't crazy that would have been
an epic win if I really you really did
you really have that much faith I did
not have any it's one of those you never
know okay that's pretty good I mean I
mean you got you got like one fifth
office hell yeah I really yeah oh that's
more than expected yeah okay okay yeah
let's uh let's let's quickly do the
whole like let's sell everything or sell
a bunch of stuff cross fingers for
elixirs we should be good to go
I who I am an exotic item dedicate er
yeah there's like it feels like there's
like a thousand of these challenges in
the game you're screwed
do you dog are you okay go we got to go
we got to open the doors so the real
question is do I just use the tompa's on
this guy I'd say so
okay got being at his own game yeah okay
especially when you've only been
proficient in for half an hour it would
be a real insult to his craft
anthro share campus how do I ever heal
he's cheating he's got guns on his
tongue
why is that already
we tried
I do have a lot respect Forte because he
does not use the sloth talisman I will
use this one Dan the talisman that
pretty much slows down the enemy
movements it seems like by 30% seems
pretty good though that one good point
where I probably should
[Music]
oh it's a grad okay
I will admit that he might be the Tompa
master but I want him to steal guns I
want him to yield
Oh what I one more try that's desam
garbage I was gonna encourage he like he
didn't lose stamina from like doing the
the explosive explosive kompis I felt a
lot more confident in my reach though
yeah yeah I like that proficiency with
like what you're used to like actually
you know crap I wonder what the level of
the first mission in the third DLC is
gonna be probably like 220 I don't know
we'll see this is unlike normal mode -
it's not even the
well now okay all right this is this is
seriously the last try I don't I do not
realize how much damage that's actually
doing it's just I guess it's like the
first DLC boss of like the last the
first DLC because he could kill me in
like two shots I remember that he was
super annoying and they got that
centipede arm mm-hmm he was fun you had
to stay away from his right side yeah I
really should not taking that damage
whoa I'm salty Miguel that's not how
we're going out I won't allow it
I didn't pick up my stupid dog
it's bad news
why was the throw
[Music]
this guy's so fast can you take over yes
oh my god to reach
I was really trying to get a lot of
stammer there did not work
because it's the patient game the long
con
[Music]
barely like hit'em more than once
whoa got lucky
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
always got para let paralytic stuff now
okay he's doing a mousse
[Music]
No
okay they were normal cognize at least
why does he appear like he's just not
dying chipping away
[Music]
okay there well yeah zigging and zagging
[Music]
while I'm at elixirs what does that move
that's the zig-zag move
[Music]
[Music]
complimented you sounds like he's gonna
go into another form
did you really compliment me though he
said oh no no no let me out
elbow he gave me the people's elbow
alright well that was the fine honor
he'll see ya first boss tompa's new
weapons new ninja Doge yes that was
pretty cool so you could get this used
light as you said mentioned earlier
stand alone $9.99 and the season pass we
can get all three DLCs is $24.99 and so
yes this is the second DLC afforded DLC
for neo defiant honor and for more
gameplay showcases keep it here at
GameSpot and be sure to like subscribe
to our YouTube channel thanks for
watching and thanks for playing Eric no
problem thanks guys
[Music]